So how do you validate the idea?
How do you not waste a lot
of time building something
that people don't need?
>> Well, I think that the thing you
need to do is just build something.
I realize that sounds a little backwards
to the way you asked the question.
But you can talk to as many
people as you want in life, and
you'll get some good answers and
some bad answers.
Unless you know how to ask
the questions properly,
you'll get a lot of bad answers.
But really the best way to get people's
feedback is to build something.
And it might not be the right thing, but
as long as it has sort of the minimal
quantitive useable functionality.
It gives people something
to interact with.
And then you start learning how they
use it, what they really want, and
you can go from there.
>> So,
if I'm an early stage startup, and
I want to do user research,
what do I do?
I just build it and
release it to the market?
>> Essentially, yeah.
It really is you know, build something,
put it out there, see what happens.
The way I would modify
that just a little and
this is why it's useful to be
your own customer is that,
if you're your own customer and if
you're building this thing for yourself,
as you start developing it, you can
actually figure out what you need and
what you don't need before you release
it and see what other people need.
If you're building something for someone
you don't understand and it's not you.
The first piece of feedback you'll get
is when you toss it out into the world.
And getting people to engage
with something is hard enough.
Getting people to engage with
something they don't actually want or
need at all is basically impossible.
So if you build something
that you need and
want, you can get it to the point
where it solves your problem.
Then you release it and other people
will be able to give you feedback and
really interact with it and
then you'll just get better faster.
You make your iterations faster.
>> And how do you make sure that you get
the right feedback
from the right people?
How do you make sure that it's not
like showing it to your mother and
she's saying, hey that's a great idea.
>> Yeah.
Well, mothers will usually tell you your
idea is very nice unless they actually
want you to go back to law school
which is what my mom keeps suggesting.
Although she suggested I go get an MBA
the other day, I don't know why.
You have to pick, right?
You have to be smart about it and
seek out the people who you think will
find what you're doing is useful.
Now, some of that actually
is picking people by hand,
looking at your network and saying,
hey, this person is the right demo.
The right user type for
what I'm building, looks like me or
doesn't look like me, but I think
I can solve their problem anyway.
Let me start with them.
The other way is try to find
some sort of distribution early.
And there's a bunch of
different ways to do that.
If you're building a product,
Hacker News, is an amazing place to go.
Because that's where a lot of people who
are interested in technology congregate.
They go there.
They see what's up.
They look at interesting articles.
We have something called Show HN, where
people just put up new products, and
they'll get a lot of feedback.
A lot of customers,
potential customers, coming to them.
You can use product hunt for
the same thing.
There's a bunch of other things
like that that you can use.
But really, it's about being relentless.
There's a great story that
Ben from Pinterest tells.
The founder of Pinterest.
And when he was starting Pinterest,
he didn't think anyone
would want to use it.
And so
he literally went to coffee shops and
showed the prototypes of Pinterest
to moms that he saw at coffee shops.
He said,
these are probably going to be my demo.
Let me see what they think.
And he had them, and
he just took notes at coffee shops.
And it's that level of drive of
just finding people who want
to use what you're building.
That's critical in getting
some sort of engagement.